society today there's no doubt that what
is happening is that women are becoming
way more non-traditional you know modern
women whereas they still want a
traditional man right this is I don't
think that's even a controversial topic
so in your opinion obviously you're more
of a traditional woman you're not a
feminist whatsoever I wouldn't say I'm
traditional I feel like traditional is a
22 year old bird I wish I was but I
wouldn't say I'm trying all right so
then then break that down and what do
you think is the ideal role for a woman
in society today with all the pressures
that come with feminism and working and
being a boss babe and marketing and and
you know you can be any weight you want
to be I know it's a loaded question but
what is the in your opinion the role of
a woman today
what what is what do I think the role of
a woman today should be
um I mean I think women should follow
Men's Leadership so I would say the
ideal relationship is where you're
following a man's lead so but are you
following a man's lead right now I'd
like to be okay but now I'm single oh I
will say I follow my dad like I would
say like
um but that's not a relationship that's
yeah I mean you know but so you're
saying that the role of a woman so so
Natalia over here she's a 25 year old
girl all right 21. all right
um any woman that's watching us out
there you're saying that their role
should be to latch on to a man and just
follow his lead is that what you're
saying yeah ideally yes but okay so I
dude how's it doing can you trust that's
be a good you know It's gotta be a good
deal listen as a dude selfishly I'm like
hell yeah you could just Bowl in line
follow my lead I get it but there's
going to be a lot of women out there
that are like what are you talking about
I'm 18 years old I'm 21 years old I
don't even have a man I'm going to
school I'm trying to make something out
of my life I've been encouraged to get
an education get a job not rely on a man
that's what a lot of women have been
told by their mother by their
grandmother by whoever so put yourself
in the shoes of a 21 year old girl and
pearl I again I kind of selfishly like
your answer but what would you say to a
21 year old girl out there who's like
what do you mean follow a man I don't a
have a man and I want to make something
of my life what would your counter
argument to that be
um I mean you can do what you want I
just think outcome wise like I just
don't think women are generally happy
when like men follow them so if you like
how else would you be in a relationship
someone's got to lead someone's got to
follow yeah so but I feel like that's
step two okay so so hear me out I feel
like step two or step three is
all right cool step one would be
like be a normal functioning element of
society be a contributing member of
society go to school get good grades be
a good person like it's a class get an
education get a job like this is normal
society yes and then once you're there
yeah step two would be like maybe meet
somebody step three is maybe you have a
boyfriend maybe step four maybe you can
engage married cool okay but step one
before you're at step three or step four
is you gotta have a role in society for
advice this is an advice oh you're a
girl no okay okay
um I mean
what what I mean she has to get a job to
eat so you still have to get a job okay
so go there
um so go say hey
if your advice is hey get good in school
get good grades and get a job that's a
that's a decent starting point yeah
rather than like I see what you're
saying follow a man figure it figure out
what type of guys you want and where are
they okay you know what I was thinking I
went to I got box seats the other day
shout out Dad okay Dad and I was
thinking I was like it'll be so
interesting if you wanted to like get if
you were into Rich guys right yeah I was
like which most women are but I don't
feel like I was like you could be one of
the girls that serves the dessert in the
bar carts I'm like two birds one stone
baby okay so like who are the guys you
want where are they by the way I'm glad
that I pressed you a little bit Yeah
because yeah your your answer of uh just
follow a man sounds great in theory but
it's not realistic we have to find like
well I think a step before that would be
where are the guys you want okay so
let's stay there for a second Pearl this
is good stuff yeah this is actually
advice for women but also advice for men
because I want to get your advice your
your perspective on the flip side you're
saying Hey listen the number one price
priority a woman should have is secure a
high value man is that essentially your
answer
you're saying follow a man to lead so
you want it to be yeah he doesn't have
to be I mean high value is like what
five percent of men so find a guy find a
guy that you try I mean again your
advice is to follow some loser you want
to be a good man okay fine I'm not this
isn't I got your question find a man so
your advice is hey where do high-value
men hang out AKA box seats up the game
all right cool but I like your advice
it's find out what type of man you want
and put yourself in a position to find
that type of man and then find that man
and then be the CEO to his CEO
right men lead women follow
is that essentially I know you don't
give advice but that's kind of
the praxeology that you're conveying no
that wouldn't be a praxial that would be
an advice Channel okay that would be
advice that would be wife's school you
know it's actually gonna be an episode
on wife school okay so let's go to
wife's school yeah what advice do you
have to be a good wife again the wives
do but um I would just say like in that
in that perspective like you talk about
where the guys you want so first you
probably have to look at like
um like income demographics so if you
have a certain income you look where are
they and then go how do you get them I
mean I think that's just
if you don't mind are you do you do you
want to get married
so I'm wondering if a man is like let's
say a man loves your content he's
hearing like marriage is a terrible
decision for men today why would why
would he want to marry you
if
oh I mean I don't I'm okay with not
getting legally married that's fine okay
is your dad okay with that
no he doesn't care he kind of says live
your life oh that's cool yeah cool so I
see what you did there it's actually a
good question she wants to get married
but also she's kind of like kind of just
like a ceremony or something I mean I'd
like to like do a ceremony ideally but I
would understand like honestly if a guy
didn't want to do the league like I know
so much about it and I think if I was in
a guy's point of view so you want him to
do like a ceremonial marriage I mean I
did why do I go personal though it's
like what I'm just curious I want to
learn about you we're friends now right
are we yeah but we worked everyone's
getting along here we're cool um all
right same question to you you're
married now I assume being the type of
person that has gone through this growth
pattern and actually improved and you
said when you were 18 19 struggling to
get no girls making no money you got to
the point now where you've developed the
roommates another standard and you were
able to lock down
a beautiful wife and that's amazing the
same question to you is what do you
think the role of a modern woman should
be I think the role of a modern woman
should be to
fulfill her purpose that God has given
her and for a lot of women that purpose
is going to be some man's wife not every
woman so to me I think it's to fulfill
that purpose and most women's purpose is
to be to be a husband be a wife to a
husband the challenging thing is I want
to clarify something every man does not
need to be married am I forcing men to
be married if you don't want to get
married you're free to not get married
so at the same time there's a woman who
disagreeable wanting to Knuck If You
Buck you know the girls that you
obviously talk about on your show we she
shouldn't get married right she
shouldn't get married because she's so
disagreeable she's so damaged she so has
so many issues and so to me I think it's
to figure out what that is and then
based upon that decision then you pursue
it right um so that's what I think I
would I would say for modern women today
I think uh what do you advise here do
you advise your men in the standard to
get married
um so great question Pearl so one of the
things for me as many of you know I was
just banned on tick tock talk and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible